امسك الملياردار الامريكي الان ماسك
بيزيما متوسر حتى بدا وكانه يقص اجنحه
العصفور الازرق ليفقد مع قراراته شيئا
فشيئا كل من كان يختار تلك المنصه
لاستخدامها اجراءات صادمه لم تتوقف بمجازر
التسريحات الجماعيه ونسف عدد الموظفين الى
النصف بل بات الى الثلثين ومع هذه
التغييرات يرمي المنتقدون بسهامهم نحو مصر
والسبب انا ماسك يتراجعوا عن الجهود
الهادفه لجعل موقع التواصل الاجتماعي
مكانا اكثر تحضرا وامانا صحيفه واشنطن
بوست اكدت ان المنصه الزرقاء اعلنت حلا
مجلس الثقه والامانه الخاص بالشركه خطوه
يراها منتقدون على انها مثال اخر قد يجعل
التطبيق مهجرا فهي ببساطه تغييرات لا تنظر
بالخير
التي اوضحت ان المجلس المنحل يتكون من عده
مجموعات استشاريه تضم خبراء تطوعوا بوقتهم
لمعالجه قضايا بالغه الاهميه على المنصه
هؤلاء تحديدا يركزون على خصيه الامان بشكل
اساسي وكيف يمنعون المضايقات والانتحار
والاستغلال الجنسي للاطفال ببساطه انهم
معنيون بحقوق الانسان الرقميه ويضم اعضاء
المجلس المنحل شخصيات من منظمه جلاد
ومؤسسه حقوق الانسان سمر ريتانز والمركز
الوطني للاطفال المفقودين والمستغلين فكيف
لماسك بتحولاته هذه ان يجعلها تويتر ما
الاذان لحوريه التعبير وهو الذي تعهد بان
يجعلها هذا الامر او لوويته الاولى
وقراراته تظهر العكس فمن لم يستقل بنفسه
وسيقيله ماسك وهذا ما حدث ويحدث حتى
الاسبوع الماضي
على ثلاثه من اعضاء المجلس الاسبوع الماضي
احتجاجا على تغييرات في المنصه الاخيره
مستشهدين في بيان بادله قالوا انها تنظر
الى ان سلامه ورهفيات مستخدمات وتر هي في
تراجع
[موسيقى]